all right I think we're going to go
ahead and get started can everybody hear
okay awesome so today I'm going to tell
you all about building iOS apps with
firebase just a quick show of hands how
many of you have heard of firebase
before okay about half half the room how
many people have built an app with
firebase alright just a few of you
before we get started a little bit about
myself I am a developer advocate on the
Google cloud platform team my name is
Sarah Robinson you can find me on
twitter at s robb tweets and I live here
in San Francisco I'm a Swiss fan both
Taylor Swift and the language Swift if I
had to choose a favorite it would be a
tough call all my code samples and demos
today are going to be in Swift and when
I'm not programming I can be found
finding the best ice cream in San
Francisco so here's what we're going to
cover today first I'll give you an
overview of what firebase is and then
I'll talk about specifically how to get
started with firebase on iOS and we'll
do a quick real-time chat demo and then
we'll do another demo of a visualizer
for the cloud vision robot using
firebase on iOS and then we'll wrap up
before we dive into the agenda I want to
start by telling a story so about a year
ago I didn't know any native mobile
development and I really wanted to learn
I'd done a lot of JavaScript I had done
some stuff with hybrid mobile frameworks
which lets you write HTML CSS and
JavaScript and it runs in the native
webview but I had never done any native
mobile development I've been an iPhone
user for a long time so I decided I
wanted to learn iOS development and I
had a couple requirements I wanted a way
to learn that I could learn pretty
quickly and focus on learning the iOS
specific aspects of development so I
wanted to learn how Xcode worked when I
build apps I didn't want to have to
focus on spinning up servers or working
on my back-end infrastructure and
firebase turned out to be a really great
tool for learning iOS development which
is why I want to tell all of you about
firebase today so now back to the agenda
what is firebase firebase is a platform
for building extraordinary apps but what
does that mean
firebase consists of three core features
and the first of those is the real-time
database I'm going to talk about all
these in detail
but the firebase database is a no sequel
JSON database and every piece of data
stored in firebase is referenced by a
URL the second feature of firebase is
user authentication so how many of you
have implemented Oh off before a few of
you how many of you enjoyed it one
person one person it's not very fun but
the cool thing about firebase is
firebase makes user authentication easy
so we take care of both on the firebase
servers all you have to do is one method
call different on each platform and
you've got users authenticated you'll
see that in demo shortly and then the
last feature firebase offers is static
hosting so this is a tool for web
developers to deploy static content HTML
CSS and JavaScript through the command
line with just one command firebase
deploy and your app is live on your own
firebase app comm domain so let's take a
look at the real time database first I
want to talk about the ability of
firebase to allow device to devices to
talk directly to the database so what we
have here is your traditional
application architecture we've got a
device the talks to an application
server which is running your application
logic and then this in turn talks to the
database with firebase the architecture
is going to look a little different with
firebase we have a two-tier architecture
so your device can talk directly to the
firebase database and this simplifies
development a lot with this two-tier
architecture development is much faster
so typically building real time apps is
something that's pretty difficult we
have things like Google Docs where users
are adding notes to documents in real
time there's a team of hundreds of
engineers behind that with firebase you
can build real-time apps as just a
single developer or a small team of
developers so development is really fast
and then firebase handles all the hard
parts for you so you don't have to worry
about scaling your app from your first
ten users to your first 10,000 if your
app is a smash hit
firebase will take care of the scaling
part for you but sometimes you will want
to run trusted server code a lot of the
firebase customers do so firebase has a
REST API that lets you connect your
server code to firebase and it's also
really easy to wire up third party API
is
fire base if you'd like to do that my
favorite part about firebase is the
real-time data synchronization which you
can see from this awesome ship so the
cool thing about firebase is that any
client that is connected to your app
shares one master copy of the data and
any client that subscribes to that will
see data updates in real time so you
don't have to pull to refresh on mobile
you don't have to refresh the page on
the web data is synchronized in real
time which is really cool so I've talked
a little bit about it let's look at some
Swift code on how you would store in
sync data in firebase so as I mentioned
before every piece of data in firebase
has its own URL so to create a reference
to your database you say let ref so it's
going to be a constant here of type
firebase and you pass it a URL this is
the URL I'm going to use for this demo
and there's two ways to write data to
firebase the first is set value in Swift
and what this will do is it'll update
the location with whatever you pass it
you can pass it a string an object a
number a boolean and it'll update that
so set value is useful in certain
situations sometimes you'll have a lot
of people writing to the same path in
your firebase database at the same time
and in this case you'll want to generate
a unique ID each time a new piece of
data is added which is where you'll want
to use this method child by Auto ID in
combination with set value so here what
we're doing is we're saying ref tot
child by Auto ID which is going to
create a pass at the root of your
firebase / a unique ID which is going to
look something like what you see in the
comment there and then you're going to
set the value at that path here we're
just setting it to a string hello again
so that's how you write theta to
firebase to read data back is pretty
simple you just attach this asynchronous
callback to your firebase reference and
this will be triggered any time the data
at that location changes so you pass
this listener and event type here we're
using the value event type this function
is going to be called any time the value
at that firebase location changes and
because firebase is a real-time data
stream it's always changing this will be
past the snapshot so it's a snapshot of
your data at that specific point in time
and here we're just printing the value
of the snapshot to the console
so now let's take a look at firebases
authentication feature firebase has
three different types of authentication
you can do basic email password auth and
you can also integrate with a number of
third party providers so if you'd like
to add Google Facebook Twitter or github
off to your app it's really easy to do
this with firebase all you need to do is
register your application with one of
these services grab your API key and
secret head on over to your firebase
dashboard paste your API key and secret
in there and then just one method call
your able to authenticate users really
easily and then finally firebase offers
anonymous off which is great if you want
to require user log in without having
users type in credentials so if you want
to generate guest user accounts and
still have some notion of securing your
data without requiring users to log in
let's take a look at some code here this
example we're using github
authentication so we just call the
method off with OAuth provider we pass
it to the provider we want to use in
this case it's github will pass it our
access token and then this is going to
return either an error or an auth data
object the AA stata will contain a bunch
of data from the git from the github
user's profile and so you're probably
wondering if I'm talking from the device
directly to the database how do I secure
my data how do I make sure that people
can't write to other users nodes and the
way you do this is through security
rules so firebase has a powerful
security language all of the security
rules are run on the firebase servers
and they're written in a JSON like
syntax that's going to match to the
structure of your data in firebase so
let's say you have a slash users note in
your firebase that dollar variable
dollar UID signifies a dynamic path so
this rule is going to apply to any child
of slash users there's three types of
security rules in firebase the first is
a read rule so this is saying that the
data at slash users slash UID is
globally readable anyone can read the
data but it's only writable by that
specific user so when you use firebase
authentication in combination with
security rules you automatically get
access to this off variable so I can do
things like sit say only this specific
user can write to their own
user node so this makes it possible to
say that you can't spoof other users in
the app the third type of rule is a
validation rule and those are run after
the write rules succeed so you can do
things like verify that the new data is
the string is a number adheres to a
certain length and things like that so a
common problem on mobile is what if your
application goes online offline so let's
say you got a chat app that you built
and your users are on a train that goes
through a tunnel they lose connectivity
they're climbing a mountain they're on a
plane wherever they may be they're going
to expect that their app will work
offline so how does firebase handle
offline situations so any data sent
while offline is persisted to disk in
firebase not just to memory which is
really powerful and when you regain
connectivity all the data you sent while
offline will be synced with the firebase
servers and you'll also pull down any
data that was sent while you are offline
so I can talk about offline disk
persistence but it's better demonstrated
with a demo and I didn't want to turn my
Wi-Fi off during the presentation so I
pre-recorded this one so what you're
going to see here is that we'll add a
one message while we're online then I'll
turn the Wi-Fi off add another message
and then you'll see what happens when I
turn it back on again so let's go ahead
and play this video so we can see I'm
online right now adding a chat message
it was added to firebase and now I'm
turning my Wi-Fi off adding another
message here we go
hello from the other side and it was
added to my app I quit the app wasn't
added to firebase yet so I'm still
offline we can see it's still saved
there I'm turning my Wi-Fi back on and
boom it was added to firebase so that's
a quick demo of how firebase offline
works
and to enable this you just need one
line of code this is what it looks like
in Swift so you just say firebase
default config and set persistence
enabled to true that's all you need to
do to get that working and then
optionally you can specify that data at
a specific location in your firebase
should be pre fetched and kept up to
date and you can do that with rest keep
synced and set that to true so now I
want to talk about the third feature of
firebase which is the static hosting
service and this lets you deploy your
static assets through the command line
which is one command firebase deploy and
all the content is served over HTTP by
default
firebase takes care of acquiring the SSL
cert for you it's backed by a global CDN
and custom domain support is available
so by default you get access to your own
firebase app comm domain you can easily
configure a custom domain if you'd like
to host your personal site on firebase
it's really easy to do this once you've
installed the firebase command line
tools you just need to run firebase in
it this will initialize your directory
with firebase hosting you only ever have
to run that command once for each
project and then after that to deploy
just one command firebase deploy it's
really fast
so just to summarize firebase has three
client libraries iOS and Android
libraries for mobile I'm going to be
focusing on the iOS client today and
then a JavaScript client if you'd like
to build web applications with firebase
and if you're a JavaScript developer
firebase has libraries for integrating
with popular front-end frameworks like
ember angular backbone and react so you
can use those frameworks for the front
end of your application and then store
all of your data in firebase and then
firebase also has a REST API so you can
access it from your favorite server-side
language so now I'd like to talk
specifically about how you can get
started with firebase on iOS any iOS
developers in the room started curiosity
okay a handful
the easiest way to use firebase on iOS
is through cocoapods for those of you
that aren't familiar cocoapods is the
iOS dependency manager and so the way
you do this is you add firebase to your
pod file this is where you describe all
of your dependencies for your
application with the correct version and
then you go to your application
directory just run the command pod
install that will install all the pods
you've defined in your pod file and then
be sure to open the x.c workspace
version of your project which will
include all the pods for you and then in
your view controller if you're using
swift all you need to do is add a
firebase import and you're ready to go
so now we're going to go into a live
demo what are we going to build we're
going to build a simple real-time chat
app and it's going to look something
like this similar to the video I just
played it'll be a basic UI tableview
which is just a list when you click on
the plus sign you'll be able to add a
new message and then the messages will
be displayed in the table view we're
going to use anonymous authentication in
the application so I can show you a
little bit about how firebase
authentication works why would you want
to use anonymous often an app let's say
you have a situation where you don't
want to require users login but you want
to have some some form of auth so you
want to have guest accounts anonymous
author be great for that and also with
anonymous author you still get access to
firebase is security rules so if you
want to enforce security rules without
requiring user credentials anonymous off
is a great way to go so I'm going to
quickly show video of how to install
firebase with cocoapods and then we'll
get up and running with some code so
we're running pod in it this will create
a pod file for us so now I'm opening the
pod file uncommenting those lines and
adding the firebase pod with the correct
version and I'm going to save and close
the pod file and then run pod install
I'm installing firebase
and now I can see the EXCI workspace
version of my project which I'm going to
open and that is it that is all you have
to do to install the firebase pod so now
if we could go to the demo cool so I've
already got a version of this
application running that doesn't use
firebase let's run it in a simulator and
see how it goes there we go so I'm going
to add a chat message I'm going to say
hello you can see it appears there
I'm going to say hello again it's there
but if I quit the app and reopen it my
message is gone which is kind of sad
it's only saved locally we want our chat
data to be persisted somewhere which is
why we want to add firebase to the
application so let's see how we would do
that so as you saw in the video all I
need to do is add a firebase import I've
already installed the firebase pod and
then the next step is to set up my
firebase reference which is going to go
to this URL and let's actually take a
look at that URL in the browser so this
is what my firebase database looks like
we make that a little bit bigger this is
where all the data from my application
is going to be stored I haven't added
any security rules yet but I'll do that
shortly
and in the log in an auth tab here you
can see that if I go to anonymous off I
have it enabled which means I have
access to that function to authenticate
users anonymously let's go back to the
data and to the application and the
first thing we want to do is instead of
adding the messages to our local
messages array right when the alert
controller is cleared we're going to add
that in a different function so I'm
going to get rid of this we're not going
to reload the tableview there anymore we
are going to instead do that in this
push to firebase function so what we
have here is a local messages array is
that and that's what we're using to
populate our table view so if we go down
here before we write that push the
firebase function the first thing we
want to do is authenticate our users and
we're going to do that in viewdidload
this is called only once in our
application lifecycle so I'm going to
say raft authen anima Slee
with completion block and what this is
going to do
is it's going to return an error and an
auth data object and here we're going to
say if there's if error is not equal to
no so if there's an error let's just
print the error to the console otherwise
let's print auth data obviously we want
to do something else with auth data but
I'm just going to show you what that
auth data object looks like first so
here we can see we've got this auth data
object with our unique ID for that
session so instead of printing it I'm
going to say self dot u ID equals auth
data UID and this self dot UI d is a
variable I've defined up here so now
that we've got users authenticated the
next thing we want to do is push that
message to firebase with the user's UID
so I'm going to create here an object
that's going to have a key of text and a
value of text which is the text that the
user has inputted into that message box
and then we're going to have a key of
user which is it going to have a value
of that UID that we set up here and then
to write this data to firebase is just
one line of code so I'm going to say
rest I'll buy Auto ID and I'm using
child by Auto ID here is because I've
got I'm going to have a lot of messages
being sent
if this app is a smash hit and I want
them to have each have their own unique
ID so I'm using child by Auto ID and
then I'm going to say set value message
data that data object that I've defined
right here so let's run this again
and I think it would be cool if we had
firebase side-by-side here with our chat
demo so I'm going to say hello GCP next
and we can see that my message is added
to firebase just one line of code with
my unique anonymous user ID if I add
another message hello again
we can see that it was also added to
firebase which is pretty cool
but you'll notice that nothing updated
in our UI so we haven't written a
listener to read data back from firebase
yet so that's what we want to do next so
going back to the code we're going to do
this in view did appear and what we're
going to do is we're going to every time
the value with this firebase is updated
we're going to add the messages to this
local array and then we're going to
update the messages array up here to
contain the contents of that local array
so that our table view will have all the
latest message data so here I'm going to
say raft observe event type and here I
want to use the child added event type
instead of value this will be triggered
anytime a new child is added to my
firebase reference and here we're going
to get back a snapshot and first let's
just print the value of that snapshot so
that you can all see what it looks like
this will be called once for the initial
data and then it's called again any time
the data changes so let's play that and
we can see what we got back here is all
the objects which are currently in
firebase so instead of printing it here
what we want to do is we want to grab
the value at the text and add that to
our local array so let's write the code
for that so we're going to say let
message text equals snapshot value dot
objects for key as I met that we method
we have access to and I want to grab the
object at the key of text and I know
that's always going to be a string so
I'm going to down cast it to a string
and then I'm going to say local array
insert message text at index 0 I'm using
an insert here instead of a pen because
I want to show the most recent messages
first
so I'll insert it I'll insert it at
index 0
and then I want to say self dot messages
equals local array so I'm going to set
the global messages array to this local
array which I'm using to populate my UI
tableview and then I'm going to say self
set table view dot reload data reload
the table view data so let's see this in
action we're building it and here we
have an ax simulator we rendered all
those messages that we just sent so let
me again pull up firebase side by side
and let's see what happens when I add a
new message woo see that my message is
added in real time and was also added to
firebase which is pretty cool so we're
we've enabled real-time sync with just a
couple lines of code and just to quickly
show you the cross-platform nature of
firebase what I've got over here is a
jsfiddle and so I'm going to write a
super simple JavaScript application
that's connected to the same firebase
and we'll see it update in the simulator
so here I'm just going to use JavaScript
I'm going to say bar ref equals new
firebase and I'm going to create a
reference to the same firebase GCP next
up firebase a comm and then I'm going to
say ref dot push text is going to be
hello from JavaScript and let's run that
and we can see that updated here and it
was also added in firebase but one thing
you'll notice is that it doesn't adhere
to this schema that I was following here
where has a text and a user child key
and this is where security rules would
come in handy
so with security rules you can see over
here I'll make this fullscreen by
default my firebase is globally readable
and writeable which is not good that
means anyone can read and anyone can
write to the data to the database here
so I should add some security rules I'm
going to do that now so I'm going to use
a dollar variable to say that for any
child of the root of my firebase this
rule should apply so I'm going to say to
write to this node
we have access to new data is going to
be whatever data is added new data dot
has children and then we're going to say
that it needs to have a text and a user
key there so if I save the rules rules
are saved and I go here to the jsfiddle
and try to add the data we'll see that
it did not succeed because of my
security rules
but if instead I come in here and say
user Sara and run this it was called
again so now we're hearing to my
security rules one other thing I'd like
to add in my security rules here is I
want to make use of the authentication
which I've added so I want to say that
auth cannot be equal to null so you need
to be authenticated - right - this
firebase so now if I go back to my
fiddle and try to run this even though
this has a text and a user child key
it's not going to succeed because I'm
not authenticated from the jsfiddle so I
just want to show you how easy it is to
build cross-platform apps you can easily
build an iOS Android and web app that
I'll do the same thing as long as
they're connected to the same firebase
database and again we did that in just a
couple lines of code so if we could go
back to slides
let's see another app so you saw a
pretty simple use case a real-time chat
app that updates a UI tableview let's
see an app that's a little bit more
complex the next thing we're going to
look at is an app I built which is a
dashboard for visualizing the cloud
vision robot how many of you have been
outside and seeing the vision robot at
the conference cool if you haven't yet
there's still time to check it out after
my talk for those of you that haven't
seen it yet you're probably wondering
what is this cloud vision robot you're
talking about it is an image detection
robot which is powered by the cloud
vision API it looks like this its name
is V bot and this is a little bit about
how it works so it's a go PI go robot
that has a Raspberry Pi running on it
and the Raspberry Pi is running some
Python code you can think of the
Raspberry Pi as the brain of the robot
and the Raspberry Pi also has a camera
connected to it so the camera takes a
picture of whatever's in front of it and
then it sends it to the cloud vision API
which is able to return a bunch of
metadata on what's in the object so
we're using the vision API as label and
face detection features here to return
some JSON on what's in the image so if
there's spaces in the image it can tell
where they are if the person is happy or
sad and if there's objects in the image
it can tell what those objects are so
the vision API returns this JSON
response and then we write that JSON
data to firebase and we're using
firebase to power the web dashboard so
if you've seen the vision bot you'll see
a dashboard that looks something like
this on the monitors nearby and it
displays the latest picture that was
taken with the bot along with the words
that it's seeing so you've got a web app
to visualize the robot and what we want
to add is an iOS app so I've taken the
robot to a couple of events so far and I
thought it would be cool sometimes I'm
walking between different demo booths
and walking between venues and I want to
check up on the BOTS make sure they're
all up and running like they should be
so I thought it'd be cool to build an
iOS app that does something similar to
what the web app does this is what the
app is going to look like it's going to
be a basic master detailed view
application so we've got a UI tableview
that's showing the
of all of the active box and then when
you click on one of the IDs it'll show
the detailed view of what that bot is
looking at so there's a picture I took
at my desk a couple days ago you can see
it recognize my face
and that I was smiling so it drew green
box around my face and I was holding up
a bottle of water the vision API was
able to identify that as a bottle of
water so what is the data going to look
like in firebase so at the root of our
firebase we have a splash box node and
then under that we have all the IDs for
our box and whenever one is updated we
want to change the color of that cell
and display how long ago the bot was
last active so here if it was active in
the last 60 seconds I'm displaying an
active now that's what the table view
looks like and this is a simplified
version of what the table view
controller code will look like so the
first thing we're doing is creating a
reference to our firebase and then we're
going to create a local bot array of F
data snapshot updated snapshot is the
data type of the snapshot that is
returned from firebase and then what we
want to do is we want to sync that data
from firebase into a local array so this
is pretty similar to what I did before
but we're listening on the value event
type and then we're going to loop
through all the bot I DS so we're going
to say for bot in snapshot children and
then within this function we're going to
sync all the data to a local array and
I'll show you it in Xcode momentarily so
then what will the data in our detailed
view look like so this is all the data
we're storing for each bot a bunch of
different data and this is all data
that's returned from the vision API so
if you look at that slash face node the
vision API returns a bunch of data on
the emotions that it detects in the
image where specific features are in
your face and then we're storing all
this in firebase along with the basic C
4 encoded image string of the latest
image and then we're also storing all
the labels at the vision API finds in
firebase so we want to loop through
those labels and display them the vision
API also returns a confidence score of
how confident is that it found that
specific label in the image so we'll
display that in the UI as well and this
is what our detailed view controller
code will look like so we create a
reference to not to the root of our
firebase but to the
path for that bot so this is going to be
slash BOTS slash whatever bot ID and
firebase references are inexpensive to
create so we can create a new a new ref
for each bot when that bot cell is
closed and so then on that bot ref we're
going to listen again on the value event
type and then we're going to grab all
the data that's being returned from the
vision API and store that in a vision
data object and then we're going to get
the basic C 4 encoded image string we
want to decode that and then display it
in our UI image view and then we're
going to get all the labels and then
we're going to loop through the labels
and display those in the UI as well so
just to show you what the format of the
data looks like I've got a few sample
responses from the cloud vision API so
this is a picture I took a couple months
ago of submit beignets in New Orleans
and I was pretty impressed with the
vision api's response it was able to
identify it as a vignette even though
it's a super close up photo that may not
even look like dessert but it said
beignet is 92 percent sure it also said
dessert and powdered sugar and then
here's an example of a face detection
response to a picture I took with a
friend so you can see it returns the
result of the emotions it detected we
can see that joy likelihood is very
likely it also returns a landmarks
object which includes a bunch of
different features in your face and XY
coordinates of where those are in the
image so now let's jump into live demo
number two if we could switch to my
computer so I'm going to minimize this
app and I'm going to pull up it's
actually I'm going to stop this from
running I'm going to pull up the bot app
and I'm actually going to have Kathy
come on up here to demonstrate this so
Kathy here has a bot
and I'm going to run this app and we're
going to be able to see what the bot is
looking at so this I believe is bot
number five five seven four and we can
see that she's holding up a flower to it
the lights are throwing it off a little
bit but could be a Christmas decoration
daisy family there we go there's the bot
in action Thank You Kathy that was
awesome
so this is what the app is doing it's
got a list of all the active BOTS I can
click on them and then I can see what
they're looking at so that's kind of an
overview of what the app does now I want
to walk you through the codes that you
can see a little bit more complex app
built with firebase so first I want to
show you the table view controller so
here we set up our firebase reference
I've got a helper class to do that and
we want to have a variable with the bot
I D because we're going to use this when
we segue from the table view controller
to the detail view controller we want to
pass that bot ID so that we can create
our new firebase reference and then we
also have our local bot array of F data
snapshots so the first thing we want to
do is in viewed it appear we're going to
attach our firebase listener and we're
going to say bar s and firebase has a
couple querying methods which are pretty
powerful they let you query by an
arbitrary child key in your firebase so
here I'm doing a query ordered by key
and remember all the keys here are going
to be that list of bot ids which you saw
in the slide and i only want to query
the bots with ID starting between
Deverell five and Deverell six all the
bots we brought to this event have an ID
of Deborah five with some other numbers
after it so I've got this query here and
I'm listening on the value event type
and the first thing I do is I clear that
local bot array and I'm going to add all
the new bot data to it so I'm going to
loop through the bots for BOTS and
snapshot children I'm going to say lead
bot snap equal bot as F data snapshot
since we know it's going to be of type F
data snapshot and then we're going to
append that to the battery and reload
the tableview that's how we set up our
table view here is where we write the
code to configure the cell so in this
line we're configuring the cell and then
remember the cell on the left side the
text
the left was the bots ID the text on the
right was how long ago the bot was
active so here we've got the bot
timestamp we're grabbing that from
firebase it's stored in firebase as a
string so we need to actually calculate
how long ago the bot was active so I've
got a helper method to do that and then
we want to configure the cell we'll set
the text label to the body and we'll set
the detail text label which is the text
that appears on the right to the active
timestamp and then we want to change the
background color of the cell depending
on how long ago the bot was active so
that it displays green if the bot has
been active in the last minute and then
the next thing we do is set up our segue
so here at did select row at index index
path this is called whenever a user
selects one of the rows in our table
view we want to prepare our segue so
we're going to set the bot I D -
whatever bot ID was selected and then
we're going to perform the segue bot
list - detail view and right here is
where we do that segue so in our
destination view controller which is
going to be the bot detail view
controller we're setting the name on
that view controller to the bots ID of
the bot that was selected and then
here's just the the functions we use to
set up our table view with our bot array
data so once we perform this segue we're
here in our bot detail view controller
which is pretty short so in here we're
just setting the title which is just the
heading on that view to the bots name
and then we're creating a new firebase
reference so this reference is going to
be slash BOTS slash whatever bot ID
we're viewing deb rel 5 in this example
and then we're adding another firebase
listener to listen to the data only for
that specific bot
so bot detail ref observe event type
we're listening on the value type again
here because we're not adding new data
to this node we're just resetting the
data every time a new image is taken by
the bot so we're grabbing all the data
returned from the vision API we can
think of this as the bots world so we
store that with the key of world and
then we basic see for decode the image
since we're storing the base64 image
string and firebase and then we get the
labels that are returned from the vision
aap
I and we loop through them and we
display them so the description is going
to be whatever the label was and then
score is going to be the confidence
score from the vision API and we're
going to display that as a percent we
add that to the label string and then we
just add some styling to the UI label so
again I just wanted to show you you know
an example of an app built with firebase
that's a little more complex than just
real-time chat and we can see that this
is super easy to do I've got a table
view controller and my detailed view
controller and all the data is
displaying in real time with firebase so
if we could go back to the slides
so just to recap as what we cover we
started with an overview of firebase
then I talked about how to get started
with firebase on iOS and we did one demo
of real time chat showed you how to
update a UI tableview with chat messages
stored in firebase and then we did a
second demo with the help from Cathy
Thank You Cathy
to show a bot visualizer app that I
built to visualize all the active cloud
vision bots and what they're looking at
at that point in time so if you want to
learn more the firebase documentation is
a great place to go
they've got awesome Doc's for every
platform iOS Android and web with
detailed guides on how to do all sorts
of things with firebase and then if you
want to learn more about the vision API
if you go to the Google cloud platform
github the cloud vision repo has a bunch
of getting started samples in all sorts
of platforms to get started with the
vision API there is an iOS sample in
Swift and objective-c and I encourage
you to get in touch with Google cloud
you can follow us on Twitter we have a
slack channel and we've got a bunch of
samples for all sorts of cloud products
on the Google cloud platform github and
thank you all for coming that's all I
got
you
you